well this is getting rough Westworld
episode seven I believe of season two
the get is I'm not gonna even try and
pronounce that I'd I failed French so
yeah
spoilers like pretty much immediately so
man where do we start you know what I'll
get my one major criticism out of the
way so it's done I don't think the time
jumping was necessary I don't think it
was necessary to begin with a
flash-forward and then backtrack to get
us up there I don't think it added a
great deal to the narrative other than
confusion at the front end which I for
one didn't appreciate so I don't think
that that whole angle was necessary and
also it leaves the whole reveal of all
the other extra Bernards as something
that is harder to recall because it's
not an ending note for the thing at the
very end and said it's a weird thing
that it starts on so I'm not entirely
sure why they did that setting that
aside though pretty pretty good stuff
and a lot of people taking a lot of
damage in this one so we lose a whole
bunch of the the sort of military or
recovery team folks were just fine I
wasn't particularly attached to them but
a lot of them went down
mave is taking a beating I this isn't a
criticism yet but I'm gonna be really
annoyed if we never see the current
mother of Maeve's daughter again and I
might go into more detail this if this
plays out the way I don't want it to
play out what I don't want them to do is
have that that mother effectively yo die
or never show up again and just may've
just inserts herself in there like I I
suppose I sympathize with me I love
maybe she's one of my favorite
characters
but as far as this kid is concerned this
other woman is her mother that is as
much her mother as May feels this girl
is her daughter so I have a problem with
just discarding that and tossing that
aside in a casual way and thinking you
can get away with it because it's the
character we've seen less of so I'm not
definitively saying they've done that
but I'm nervous that they're gonna do
that and if they do I'll be ticked but
okay so moving off of that Maeve is in
rough shape I was you know what I was
kind of surprised that Delores and I
rang rack up a higher body count I am
surprised that she didn't end up killing
Tessa Tessa Thompson's character I was
surprised that she didn't kill Maeve
although that one was slightly more
believable based off their interaction
and she didn't really let Tessa
Thompson's character go she just didn't
get to her just didn't get around to it
before things you know got you know too
hot and so talking about it Harrison the
man in black they are gonna have to
address I mean first of all that was
really cool and really good having his
approach to this place be evocative of
Maeve's overriding memory of a time that
he killed her and I so I like that I
like that he still thinks this is all
part of a game for him and he in this
case he has stumbled onto something that
is not was not part of anybody's plan
and I like that the way Maeve turns
Lawrence is not through outright
manipulating his mind but by opening up
his mind to his past memories and that
is what makes him turn on the man in
black so it was as far as that Harris
goes right now they are really gonna
have if if he's still alive which I
assume that he is they are really gonna
have to address that because he's kind
of in the middle of nowhere
his own medical skills ID I feel like we
haven't
really established that he's great at
that and I mean I could I could by he'd
do a you know a basic patch job but I at
this point he has been shot in both arms
one leg and that last one looked like a
gut shot even if we go generous and say
that missed every major organ which is
unlikely but let's go there any one of
those a person could bleed out from so
it it's gonna take a lot for for me not
to feel like it's a cop-out when he
shows up alive next up well either next
episode of the episode after whenever he
shows up still alive I feel like that
that's gonna need more of an explanation
than just he's a stubborn bastard him
yes he is a stubborn bastard but that's
a lot of getting shot at the same time
but that was a real cool scene I did
enjoy that it does look like they're
building to something with the ghost
nation which I am really looking forward
to I've been kind of waiting you know
was and this isn't specific to this
episode well I suppose it is because
something I saw here sort of clicked it
in my head because when the when the
host is seducing my partner I just ended
up doubling him grease trap the security
the security military guy with really
greasy hair and she's like seducing him
to get close and they should post a pen
when she was seducing her and the fact
that she didn't take her clothes off and
he didn't attempt to do that to her made
me kind of realize like they haven't
done the exploitation through nudity
this season which makes me very happy
and it makes me more okay with the
degree that it went on in the previous
season I still think they overdid a
little bit but it is holding true to the
thematics because the first season it
fed into the theme of the hosts as
objects as something for entertainment
as not people and showing how
they were disrobed and treated in a
sexual management and managed sexual
manner really fed into that theme and
having it basically stop for this season
shows that it it was being used for
thematic purposes and not strictly for
titillation it did serve a purpose and
since that narrative function was
already established that season we don't
need to see a whole bunch of naked hosts
this time and I really do appreciate
that because it gives proper weight to
the degree to which it was done in the
first season I do still think they did
it more than was necessary to make the
point even in that first season but the
the it was just kind of nice to realize
that Bernard Jeffrey Wright is doing
really really great work he is this is
gonna sound like an insult but he is so
good at looking confused and that's
actually surprisingly hard to do
convincingly and yeah because it's not
just a look of confusion it's a look of
like trying to work it out but not being
able to put the pieces together
the way forward is reintroduced I find
really interesting and it tracks and
I've been nervous
ever since there have been lines like
you don't know what this place is really
for or things like that I've been like
oh god what kind of BS kind of revealed
but honestly the sort of flipping on his
head of who of how things were being
refined and what data was being taken
that it's all about cataloguing the
actions of the guests in order to better
break down and understand on a
mathematical scientific algorithmic
level the human mind that actually makes
sense
that doesn't feel like a cheat it
doesn't feel like it negates what we
already knew about this show and the
setting in these characters so yeah that
played out pretty well I'm frustrated
with Ford that he's kind of taken away
at least a portion of
Bernard's free will that irritates me
but it's also supposed to irritate me
like I'm not supposed to be happy about
that and not and Anthony Hopkins is
still killing and this party's really
good for that so yeah I don't think I
have too much oh you know what it also
occurred to me this episode we really
gotta find something for Felix and
Sylvester to do they're the two tech
guys that Maeve was dragging you along
cuz I don't think we've done anything
this season like they've given the
writer guy some decent moments actually
the point that I kind of like him now
but like those two guys right now are
just total Tagalongs so yeah they gotta
figure out something to do with them
because right now there's no point Oh
coming back to Tessa Thompson one more
time I am really enjoying how ruthless
she is it has really been interesting to
understand just how deep that that runs
I think that's about it it was good it
left a number of things in places were
like I could see where things could go
wrong so like if we never see that kid's
mother again if Ed Harris just shows up
again and is fine
like that there are ways that that what
I've seen in this episode could go wrong
but this season honestly it's been
really solid so I'm relatively confident
that that things won't go wrong and now
that I've said that I probably jinxed it
but we'll see in about a week so
Westworld what were your thoughts on the
latest episode whatever they are drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do
there's likes and subscribes and I've
got a patreon and all sorts of stuff
special thank you to joel johnson who
did the thumbnail and also the new end
car that you're about to see in a minute
so props to him and i look forward to
working with them some more so that will
do it everybody until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]